like if i married a guy okay and he was
a hard-working ambitious driven man
right that's what we're attracted to so
if tomorrow he stops doing those things
i'm not going to be attracted to him
anymore
where a girl could just do nothing and
like the guy is in love with like who
she is yeah
yeah and so
um a lot of times when guys find the red
pill they get angry because we just
cannot love the way that they love and
so if guys can't measure up to women's
standards then they they just start to
get angry because they realize they're
going to end up alone and that's where
you get like the red pill rage yeah and
it's hard because when you start
looking into that red pill content
like especially for me personally when i
did start looking into red pill content
it was like you start having like
epiphanies and wow okay i didn't realize
that before oh okay i was you know just
chilling with girls and in my head i was
thinking uh
that i would have you know i'll do that
but it's like i'm thinking is that bad
thoughts and whatnot and it's like it's
that red pill told you no don't suppress
that that's your masculinity side in it
that's just your masculine side and
whatnot and the best thing to do is just
remove yourself from that situation kind
of thing and work on yourself and stuff
like that because
i think before the red pill
a lot of guys do like putting effort
into girls
because we we love women we mean we love
women we want to be around women you
know women bring
peace sometimes and um
and you know you want to be around
female energy but
i think with
with the feminism movement and all the
things that they've portrayed and
whatnot it's like
we love him to a scent of
removing our own masculinity and stuff
like that so when i started getting into
the red pill that's why i started
understanding okay
you know i get it now would you say
that's because innately we are taught
that masculinity is kind of bad
i think in this day and age we are yeah
because think about it toxic masculinity
is a thing that is widely said but if
you use the words toxic femininity
you're all of a sudden a bad guy all of
a sudden you're you're this weird guy
but if men if masculinity has toxic
traits then how can feminini not have
you know i i hear toxic femininity but
it's by feminists by girls that are like
calling girls more traditional toxic
which is it's the crazy thing the phrase
doesn't tell the same weight when it
goes the other way no no it's like they
just use the toxic
to
when it benefits them basically do you
think it's too late for women to be
treated traditional some i i think after
the development of birth i i don't think
it was feminism and necessarily i think
it was more the development of birth
control and the lack of consequences for
women okay so when before women valued a
guy that was
a provider more
because
i want to say roll up tomorrow i would
like to give rolo credit because a lot
of these ideas are from rollo but
basically when the birth control pill
came out it gave women the ability to
sleep with the guys that had the genes
that they wanted with no consequence and
then still marry the provider guy later
wow
yeah and before that girls couldn't have
access to those guys because the the
consequence was too high they might get
pregnant and he might leave
but now we we have the pill
and so it gets rid of the consequence
and then on top of that if even we can
get married to the provider guy that
we're not attracted to
maybe have a couple kids by him and then
get child support divorce him take half
his stuff and we're chilling
and so it's like we're taking away the
consequences for women in society
and so why would women be better if
there's no incentive to be better
and simps will still date the girl
that's been like ran through by
everybody
have you heard the statistic about um i
forgot where it was
but it said basically out of um
all children tested for dna by their
mother and father about 33 percent of
those kids under that yep that's crazy
yeah
that's that's crazy
out there raising kids that are not
theirs one in three yeah because the
girl it's a mating strategy so the girl
got the genes from the guy she wanted
and the resources from the guy she that
she wasn't as attracted to
it's wild that's wild
there's a lot of statistics that you i
think that's i think that's a guy's
worst nightmare yeah raising a kid
that's not his and he thought that's his
and there's no there's no legal
ramification for it either i think if
you trap a guy and you know that that's
not his kid or there's a possibility
it's not his kid yeah and you let him
spend that money i think one you should
pay him double what you took and two you
should you should go to jail for the
amount of time you spent doing that yeah
i think in that in this day and age that
kind of
bill
it wouldn't pass oh no not at all this
is just if i ever ran for vote for pearl
i'm not running for anything but if i
ever do
um
so and another interesting stat i found
out one out of three men report no sex
in the last year under the age of 29
report no sex in the last year or that
they're virgins
and so that goes back that's true
well
i can't speak for me but you know this
that says it
but i believe it's true it's one of
those things where like again you can't
see once you see it you can't unsee it
yeah what type of thing is there though
like you said like you said earlier when
you were saying how
the the funny guy the
the sports guy that all those guys are
seeing and there's all those guys in the
middle right
think back to uh when you were like in
secondary school time
who was who was pressing pressing things
yeah right it was the popular ones the
the nerdy guys the guys were inside
didn't talk to girls until later on in
their life all right and then by the
time they got to the stage of talking to
girls their pool is really low because
one they're unattractive physically
because like let's be let's be honest
most people who do maths and science and
those like indoors things aren't the
most attractive people right so adam the
the
low and the tottenham poland looks
b they're probably socially awkward to
some extent because they haven't been
around that many people because they
have been indoors grinding on whatever
they're doing
right and then all of that adds up into
them just like
never speaking to a female that's either
not in the same field as them
or like not in the same like hobby group
this time yeah because where else is he
going to find a female if they're not in
like the in at work or at the places
that he likes to go to because
what girl's going to a let's say he's
really nerd what go what what 8 out of
10 nine out of 10's going to like a
comic book store like or like comic-con
or one of those like laughing
conventions not many
[Music]
but that's what makes it hard didn't it
that's what makes it hard for those guys
and those guys do i feel like yeah they
do build up the majority of men
and those like one in a million kind of
guys
are the ones that
girls are usually chasing yeah
which
and
another and this isn't just now it's
absolutely historically 8 000 years ago
guess how many women reproduced for
every one man
guess how so so for every girl that
reproduced
like for every one guy that reproduced
guess how many girls reproduced for him
i don't even want to know
i don't even know
ten to one okay what do you think i'll
probably be like eight eight
can i say ten ten yeah same i'm thinking
a little bit higher because what do you
think take into account like the
definitely yeah
taking two because i do know
i'm going to take i'm going to take a
shot in the dark and go 1-25
you're closest what
17 women reproduced for every one man
eight thousand years ago yeah
so this is
17. genghis khan did have a lot of
kids like a lot of people in asia are
descendants of wasn't that like partly
to do with like mortality partly to do
with finding the best quote-unquote male
to pass on the genes it's just a bunch
of things added together well yeah i
mean i i'd imagine
when you have to
protect women in order to reproduce with
them there's only a small percentage of
men that can do it and the ones that can
i if i had to guess i i didn't actually
see it the numbers so i don't know how
it divides but i bet there was a small
percentage that had like a stupid amount
of concubines
where
maybe
the rest it was like less if i had to
guess yeah
i could see that i could see uh didn't
henry the effect eight was
yeah and that's just some reason we're
not even going back
i feel like that's the same
nowadays it's just not i seen as much
in the states i think in um
in utah they taped a show called sister
wives and it was
um
in the mormon community i don't know if
everybody in the mormon community
participates in this but they
believe in having multiple wives well
the ones that were on the show and they
had their own little houses they had our
own little community each man had like
two or three wives and they would talk
about bringing on another one and so i i
can understand it it's crazy to think
that but
um it's still happening nowadays and
it's
would you guys ever be open to having
having a sister wife no no what if it
was between that or being homeless would
you do it yes
i would do it if it was over being
homeless tried to share dude or be
homeless
i would pick sister wife no
for me like i told you an
or the day before this i've been
homeless before so i'm just like i can
get out of that situation i wouldn't i
wouldn't want to
be a sister wife because i know that i
wouldn't be i'd be happier homeless and
by myself than being a sister wife yeah
true so
it just sounds so miserable though it
sounds invisible do you think so
yes because for how long for me for for
how long mm-hmm
that's the first fun
this isn't a caveated question it's
homeless
it's like this is women
that's not the question i asked
said you're homeless
are you good to be in a house with
sisterhood
if i could never get out of it and then
i would i'll settle for being a sister
one
you know but i better be the first one
i'm going to be the main one no you're
second yeah jesus
then i'm gonna have a side piece as well
[Laughter]
i really don't think that could ever
work because i remember watching a video
um for like uh brother husbands or
whatever you just said i watched a video
of this girl she was with a dude and
then she was talking to
the her main guy i couldn't remember if
it was her husband or not and they were
talking about adding another dude and
then they added on two more and they're
sitting there she's pregnant and they're
like who's the baby father and they're
just awesome they look miserable if you
ever get a chance
yeah but that's yes yeah but that's the
other way around yeah that's what i'm
saying that doesn't go with nature one
woman having many men yeah
like with um the one guy having multiple
wives that goes with nature more yeah
i'm not saying
i would pick it over homeless i wouldn't
really pick that
but
but i i do think
i i think one mom and one dad is the
most conducive for families but i do
think girls can
share a guy better than men can share a
woman